last week we talked about
we went quantum we had dr quantum show
us the way
um and this week we're going to go
quantum
for electrons right that's what we're
going to do this week
um these are my two favorite uh quantum
mechanicists of all time
uh i believe that this sign is meant to
teach us
something about the double slit
experiment and just as you're
leaving the lot knowing that there is
some chance
that your one car could actually split
into two
go through both exit and recombine just
like an electron does
through two slits and in fact we know
that that's possible now
um and and if we you know if we wanted
to
you could write down from de broglie you
could write down
like the wavelength of a car right so
like in a car
i don't know your lambda of the car
would be
equal to h over mv
and and if you plug some numbers in this
is going to be something like oh
you know maybe 10 to the minus 37 meters
it's small but it's a wave
your car is a wave you know the baseball
is a wave the electron
we are all waves and i know and that's
what so the electron is a wave
and i know hashtag we hashtag we are all
waves because
it's a thing it's really a thing because
it's true
i am a wave you are a wave we
are all waves it just our wavelengths
are pretty small but they're not
zero and and so the next time you oh
we're on the same wavelength
you really are like it's true
we are right that's deep we are waves
all of us and so you know the wavelength
now
this okay the wavelength for an electron
was something like 10 to the minus 10
meters which made it a really nice way
to sort of
you know use to interrogate images and
that was my why this matters last week
right like so on on friday so
so you can take advantage of that
wavelength to do things
like c electron microscopy
right but everyone's a wave that's what
quantum mechanics
told us um but what we want to do now is
know how to
how to represent this wave so
everything's waving
we got that but how do i describe it
right and and and that's where we left
off right and we left
off by by me telling you that it all led
to schrodinger
who came up with the wave equation for
quantum mechanics and the wave equation
of schrodinger
is really pretty uh pretty incredible
because
you know so i'm going to write i'm not
going to write out schrodinger that
would take me forever
so i'm going to write s eq
right the schrodinger equation
right and and here what was what he had
is he had the sort of
wave behavior
that was captured and it was captured
automatically and it gave us
also allowed energies you see
so allowed energies and this
is also the quantization
ah i ran out of room right but now if
you go back to like classical
so if you think about classical physics
well what you would have is something
like maybe f equals m
a but what that gives you well
it doesn't give you wave behavior but it
gives you continuous
energies continue us energies
right and so this comes the powerful
point here is that from that equation
and we don't need to know
this equation we're not going to derive
it right today i'm going to tell you how
it's solved but you don't need to know
how to solve it but you need to know
what
the solutions mean that's what we're
talking about today
but that equation what it does is it
sets up
the energies as a function of the wave
psi that function psi is the wave
function
okay and and so you get waves by default
because that's what you're solving for
are these waves and then you have a
minus second derivative oh there's an h
bar
that's an h over two pi
right but so but it's like the same
planck's constant
okay but the wave equation the wave
behavior gives you
because there's only certain energies
that solve that equation so quantization
falls out naturally you don't have to
put it in anymore
it is a direct result of solving this
equation
if i take a wave it needs to think about
this right
if you take a wave and you put it in a
box right
then it can it can only have certain
solutions once you define the box
if you throw a wave in it well maybe you
know that's where those things there on
the right are
you know if maybe it's a standing wave
and so
it's going to look no
it's going to be like this one solution
and some energy
or maybe it's gonna look i i didn't
leave myself
any room like this
and it's gonna have some other energy
right
one two that's a if you throw a wave in
a box like here's
first one second one but there are only
certain ones that are going to work
right you can get that that sense
because otherwise it's not going to line
up and then be able to wave
and keep going it's not going to be a
standing wave
right so you get this sense right away
of quantization
only certain waves and only certain
energies will solve this equation now
here's the key is this
we're going to throw an electron into
this equation
right but we're going to throw it into
the right potential
and that is the potential that we know
it sits in in an atom
which is simply a coulomb potential
so this is how we get there right we
take schrodinger's equation of quantum
mechanics
and we take it we solve it for an
electron
waving in the presence of the feet of
the potential
of the atom which is a positive a
positive potential you can see this is a
okay v is the potential and that's an
attractive potential right
that's an attractive potential so what
happens when we do that so that's what
we're going to do
now i'm going to leave this for so what
happens so
if we take a hydrogen atom
or as i've written it here a atom
then you would have okay so then you
would have let's see
what do you get from this well you get
that the potential is going to be minus
1 over r yeah it goes as minus 1 over
you know an e and an over permittivity
of space and stuff like that
but it's like it goes as minus 1 over r
that's the coulomb
potential right a plus charge
is sitting outside
of a minus charge
that was a close call electron is
sitting out here
and there's the nucleus right and the
potential feels is a coulomb potential
okay so that's point one
uh point two is that we're going to
apply the oh i'm saving myself
so much time i love it when you're
efficient like that
s eq schrodinger equation the
schrodinger equation
and but the way that we're going to do
this is in spherical coordinates
okay spherical
chords and all that means is that
i'm going to write psi as
a function of r
theta and phi
and the last thing that i'm going to do
is i'm going to
separate the variables and that's just a
standard way to solve
mathematical equations right so i'm
going to separate the variables so
separate
and so so what that means
is that psi can be written
as one function let's call it r
of the radius times another function
p of the theta
times another function f of phi so
that's my
separation of variables okay again
i'm not all about having you know how to
solve this equation
okay that you can learn in in quantum
mechanics
but what i'm all about is what that
quantum mechanics solution
means for us here in chemistry and this
is deep this is deep because why
because each this this whole thing is
quantized
right so so just like before
you know so there's only certain
allowed values for the wave function
there's only certain allowed
allowed values for these
variables each one of them is quantized
each one of them okay and that's what we
need to learn about today
is what that means for chemistry all
right
so now we're gonna go through
the quantum numbers and see what they
mean and we're gonna start
with this first one the radial
the radial function right so we're gonna
so radial
and then two angular functions okay
now the radial so what what do we get
well so
the radial function oh i'm
using a word here i got to tell you why
orbital
of hydrogen right so i've solved this
now i've solved this equation and i'm
plotting
this orbital right for
oh first quantization n equals one n
equals two
n equals three we gotta talk about this
right but i'm just plotting what that
function looks like
okay well let's compare because if i'm
bore then what i have
is this remember this i've got like this
okay there's one and it's going around
and it's very happy in an orbit
but see we don't call these orbits
anymore
and and it's going to be clear as we
talk about this picture because these
aren't
distinct orbits right so now
in quantum
what you have i'm just going to take
that n equals 1
solution that's the first solution to
the radial
part right that's not a fixed distance
that's not a fixed distance right so now
i this this i'm just looking at the
radial distribution
of the probability the probability of
finding the electron that's how we speak
when we speak quantum we don't say it's
here
right we say it could be here i don't
know but there's a probability that it's
there so now
it sort of has a probability cloud
now it looks like it gets a little less
why am i drawing spirals it looks like
it gets a little less
probable as you go further out right so
maybe the density of probability because
look
right it's got a peak there but even
if i just plot that first orbital
even as i go all the way out to here
there it is non-zero
right so this is probability
right and this would be n equals 1.
so it's it's a totally different story
that electron
isn't in one place but it is
but it's not it could be anywhere it
could be
if i'm a hydrogen atom my electron could
literally be across the room there is a
finite probability that that's true
and we know that since we are all waves
and we can all be defined by the
equations of quantum mechanics and in
fact that is
the way to define the world that we also
have probabilities
they're small you know but i could be
over there right now
it's there's a chance my wave function
is not exactly zero
all the way over there it's close but
it's not exact
right that is a very different picture
of an electron in an orbit in fact it's
not an orbit
it's an orbital and that's where
we say orbital
that's why we say okay but we're listing
quantum numbers
these are the quantum numbers oh
oh i'm going all caps
i didn't even know i was going to do
that
so we have n which is called the
principle
principle quantum
number and this is this is
going to be related to the main energy
kind of like you know e1 1 right e2 2 so
this is going to be related to
the main energy level main
energy level
right and it's also related to the
radial distance
radial distance
and sometimes we call this a the shell
so sometimes the principal quantum this
is the shell
right it's the first shell or the second
shell right
so we can call this the shell
come back to that later and you can see
right
right there okay we'll talk about angles
two and three in a sec
but you know oh let's talk about it now
you can see right right there if i go to
from
n equals one to n equals two then
i'm further out yeah i still got
non-zero it doesn't quite go to zero
like i just said there
right but it but it's it's further out
it's shifted out right so
with increasing n right so another thing
we can say about
n is that with
increasing increasing
n you get
higher energy
higher energies and larger
larger distances larger r
a whole but you get something else you
get something else and you can see it
there
and i've been avoiding it but i got to
address it right now because
those higher end functions go to zero
right so they have nodes
with increasing n you get more nodes
what's a node a node is when it goes to
zero
and there's more of them now that's also
really important
uh so what you know what that means is
it says in bohr my
orbit was r e
heisenberg said no way can't have them
both
but i had a r which was one value and
remember
it could only then be the r of the next
value the next n
now i'm basically saying the opposite
i'm saying well actually
r can be anything there's a probability
cloud
so this electron could be anywhere with
certain probability
except not here
in this one place this node
it's zero it's literally zero the
probability of finding the electron
there is zero it cannot exist there
but you know how bizarre is that the
electron
can exist with with probability out here
and probability in here but it can't
exist in between
it's the same electron right
try explaining how it goes back and
forth it skips over
a zero probability part r
right but these nodes are are very
important and just to give you a sense
of
of what this means i i found a very
fancy animation because i want to make
sure you guys understand so here's the
electron
it's doing this it's doing its waving
thing but look at what happens at the
nodes
uh-uh the probability there is always
zero you see that
can't go no not gonna not gonna exist
there
right that is super deep
because it there's no classical analog
to these things
there's no classical analog but this is
what electrons do
in an atom now this is what the clouds
look like a little better drawn than
mine
for n equals one n equals two and n
equals three so again you can see
this is one electron it's colored
differently just to contrast it but this
is one electron
right and these are you know plus and
minus of this right so it'd be like a
wavy wave
and you're just showing plus and minus
with the yellow and blue but that node
in between is where it can never
be but it's one electron it's not many
it's one
and this is its probability distribution
now i want to make one really important
point which is that you know
i look look at what i'm plotting here
maybe something that's
psi squared right so it's only the
square
of the wave function that we can relate
any physical meaning to
the physical meaning i just related to
you is the probability of being
somewhere
that's what psi squared gives us the
probability of being somewhere
but ask your teacher not me your quantum
teacher
ask what psy means and they're going to
have a
it's going to be an interesting class
force the issue don't let them go
until they answer we still don't know
we still don't know what the actual wave
function means
physically we cannot attribute a
physical meaning to it only to its
square
so we go about our business for the last
hundred years squaring it and saying
okay well it describes nature that's
great but no one
still knows what it means without the
square
right i find that incredible and it led
boar to say all sorts of really cool
things
um he said we must be clear that when it
comes to atoms
language can be used only as in poetry
the poet too is not nearly so concerned
with describing facts
as with creating images and establishing
mental connections
that's bore like deep in it trying to
figure out what sy means
he's like i don't know it's poetry
okay that's cool that's cool
v squared means something v doesn't
really no
classically we got nothing right
quantum mechanics oh it's a beautiful
thing why does this matter i'm going to
give you a brief why this matters
and you know we've been talking about
the quantum nature of things
right quantum is this quantum are these
differences
it's this probability it's quantization
of energies
what does that mean right well last time
i told you
that it you know by electrons being
quantum and having wave-like character
we were able to use them to see things
and it started the nanotechnology
revolution about 30 years ago and today
i want to give you an example
of that in my why this matters um
and and it has to do with quantum
domination
which should be the title of a movie or
a book
um and here's the example take a piece
of bulk material take a piece of silicon
okay and if you look at the silicon it's
kind of boring to look at optically it's
not very interesting
you know don't tell that to your iphone
which has a lot of it in there
but it's it's boring but now take out
your little nano
ice cream scooper which you all have and
you take a little tiny piece of it
we call that a quantum dot why
we call it a quantum dot because it kind
of looks like a dot
small ish but we call it that because
quantum mechanics
takes over the properties here's an
example shine light
on this thing or have it glow and all of
a sudden instead of being
boring it can be any color you want why
because if i shine light and here's a
very sophisticated
uh picture of a laser you can tell i had
trouble making transparent
um and so you you shine a laser on this
piece
we know already light excites
charge in an atom it does the same in
solids so here's my semi
here's my piece of silicon and what that
does is it sends an electron
up in energy levels yeah but the
electron is up in an energy level and it
left behind
a hole which is something we'll talk
about later when we talk about
semiconductors
a hole is just a positive charge and
it turns out that that electron and that
hole are attracted to each other but not
they can't get too close
but they want to kind of hang out at a
certain distance where how far
yeah quantum mechanics n
2 3 4 tells us it tells us how far
right i don't want to hang out this far
and then all of a sudden i've nano
scooped them out
and i've made a quantum dot but if i try
to do the same thing there
that's how far they want it to be and
they can't be they literally ran
out of real estate they ran out of atoms
they cannot be out here because there's
no stuff out here so they get squeezed
i am squeezing these quantum mechanical
objects this electron
in this hole and by squeezing them
i'm changing the way they interact with
light i'm
changing the color right
oh it's all stuff we've learned that
explains something
revolutionary by the way if you buy a
q-led tv
is it as good as oled no but is it
better than
led yeah a little bit that's what the
qled quantum
is quantum dots they have coded the led
emitters with quantum dots to give you
better color
now um what this means why this matters
is nothing less than the periodic table
itself because
you know i think i showed you this kind
of you know we're living in these
different ages which i love
we have the periodic table that has the
ability to work with it
is what's brought us to the age of
materials design right
but see um now
i've literally just told you that by
changing the size nothing more than the
size
i can tune a property because of quantum
mechanics
because i'm changing its quantum
mechanical interactions it would be like
saying
i can take a piece of this table i can
break a piece of this table
and it's now going to be red that's
that's exactly what we're doing but at a
very
tiny size that is as if we are taking
this periodic table and giving it a
whole
another dimension every element now
can do more things than we thought
possible because
we can tune these properties related to
quantum mechanics
right so that's a big deal that's a very
big deal
okay now back to our back to our
solution to the schrodinger equation
for an electron in an atom because now
we move on
right and and we solve for
the next one which is
okay so we had we did r now we're going
to do
theta and what happens with theta is you
get another
quantization of that variable and
that's the second quantum number so
we're going to put it here and
maybe i should oh i'll number them so we
don't lose track
who knows how many they'll be
okay not three
okay so the second one is l
and it's the angular
quantum number
and it has
also quantization zero one
two three okay so l can be
oh i need to put that up there i meant
to put that right here
this is just like what we learned for
bore
right
and l can be 0 one
two all the way up to l minus one
okay i'm going too fast that's n minus
one
l goes from zero to n minus one
now um uh okay so
what that means right away what you can
see if it only goes to n minus 1
then for like for example for n equals 1
then l equals zero that's it
there's no other options it stops
right and and we have a name for this we
call this s
the s orbital
right um and for n equals two
um l can be zero
or l can be one and this one
is called this one is the p orbital
this is the p
orbital okay those have names and so on
and so on d f these are from
this is old notation that we cannot get
rid of
these are from this is called
spectroscopic notation because it comes
from spectroscopist
and remember i told you never make a
spectroscopist angry
don't do it don't do it and so we use
their their notation still
s was sharp spherically symmetric
p was principle because it sort of
dominated in some experiments d was more
diffused
f fundamental because it looked kind of
like the hydrogen atom sometimes
these shouldn't be the names but they
are because they still stay with us
spectroscopic notation spdf what they
really do is just correspond
that is that looks like orbital
yeah let's put a little more space there
p orbital
right because what they really mean
is nothing more than a quantum number
for the second quantum number which is
the angular quantum number
these are also sometimes called
subshells right
because they're underneath the shell
and as you can see from this picture it
it describes the
angular shape
the angular shape of the orbital the
shape
right so it gives us a shape
now
if we think about it and we think about
that p
orbital right that has a different shape
than the estrogen
then um what do you think well but this
could be aligned
in different directions right so if i
think about that p orbital well i could
align it in three different ways
it could go along this axis this axis or
that one
right and so and so those are p orbitals
in hydrogen
that have three possible orientations
and that
automatically gets us to another quantum
number
in fact it's the last one and it makes
sense just physically that's phi
right so the last one
oh is it the last one is m
and we call it m sub l which is the
magnetic
quantum number okay
and this one can have quantization equal
to
minus l right all the way up to
plus l so the number of orientations
that the orbital can have right is that
if if i'm a p let's see if i'm a uh
let's see n equals two
l equals one then
m sub l equals minus one zero
or one three orientations
right it's got three orientations three
possible
magnetic quantum numbers why is it
called the magnetic quantum because
that's
uh how those are the experiments
were done using you know magnetization
magnetic fields
um to discover this this or these
orientations
to sort through it to see it
okay so if i had l equals right so if i
had for example
um l equals 2
then m sub l would have five values
five possible values right
i should put a plus there just to be
sure we keep track of minus and plus
these are quantum numbers that means
they're integers
right but but they can have this these
ranges and these rules
and again why did you know you might
think why did this come out like this
well it comes out
from solving this equation
separation of variables with that
potential
that's it right that's it you get
these allowed values of these three
variables
quantum numbers okay all right
now oh and there's the d these are
called
d well so if l equals um
so n equals two okay so and did i
did i mess up here l equals no i didn't
because n would have to be 3 here
right for l to be 2 because
l can't be equal to n because i wrote it
there as the list of
allowed quantum numbers that l can have
right
and there it is for the d orbitals
right and so there's five d orbitals
five d orbitals and you can do f
on your own and it's an extremely fun
thing to do at night late at night now
this gives you
the orbitals you get them all these are
the orbitals
these are the beautiful beautiful
orbitals that we have
from quantum mechanics describing an
electron
in an atom which tells you
everything about where that electron can
be
how it behaves what its energies are
and therefore literally y atoms are what
they are
that's what it tells us right so because
the next thing we need to do is
is fill up our atoms right and know how
electrons fill atoms using these quantum
numbers
and then relate that to chemistry and to
the differences between one atom and
another and explaining
why atoms are different remember that
was our goal
we needed to go quantum to answer that
now um okay so we're getting closer
but we're still not there and one of the
reasons is there is a fourth
quantum number and this came out of
experiments
i thought that i would just show you a
very quick video
because it's easier to see this in
action
right and so this is these are
experiments that were done
uh by stern and gerlack that showed
something very peculiar
about atoms and their electrons okay so
here i'm just gonna play it
it's got a really nice oh that's loud
yeah i don't mind that that's good but
you can read the text here okay so
they've got a magnet very strong magnets
right magnetic field and they're going
to shoot a classical magnet
there's a classical magnet and you see
it's going to react to the magnetic
field
and be pushed up but that magnet could
have been oriented differently like
sideways right in which case it doesn't
feel this
and you can throw a bunch of them
randomly with random orientations
and that's what you would see
it's good music too but now watch this i
love the animation here
look at this and the bass
right those are what happens to atoms
with electrons
you shoot them through a high field and
you don't get
anything you get two things only two
[Music]
so i definitely
i'm just playing it because i really
want to groove out and i'm
i'm debating okay so
i'm done i was debating how embarrassing
it would be if i just started grooving
out um
the the so so this is stern and gerlock
who who who discovered essentially a
fourth
quantum number that can have only two
values
so so they showed that this this this
this thing that the atoms were doing was
because of the electrons
and that the only way you could explain
what these electrons were doing
is if there was this thing called spin
and if you really need to think
classically and it's dangerous to do
so because then you'd forget that i
could be all the way over there
right right now but if you really need
to think classically you think of a
charge spinning
right it could be spinning this way or
that way this you know in a way it helps
our classical needs
but it's still not what's happening but
it does help our classical
desires right and that would give you
the two fields
right but i would advise you just to
think about spin
as simply a fourth quantum number right
and so we call that one number four
not from that equation separate from
those experiments
and that is um uh we call that
the spin m sub s is the spin quantum
number
and it's the fourth one in our series
fourth quantum number and it has only
two values
up or down or
if you like you could write it as plus a
half or minus a half
or you could write it as up or down
arrows
so many ways to distinguish two things
that are opposite
spin up spin down two values that this
can have
now pow now okay so we're not ready yet
we're still not ready we're so close
but we're still not there right
um because we still don't know well can
i just
how do i what are the rules here gonna
be
um uh you know for populating atoms
and and this is where paulie uh said
something very important and and made
this incredibly important uh
statement which is that no
particles in the same system noah read
that as
no electrons in the same atom can have
the same quantum numbers
right no electrons in the same atom can
have the same
quantum numbers and and that immediately
tells you
right again this has to do with the
nature of quantum mechanics
what that immediately tells you is
that two electrons
this is big two electrons
i'm gonna write two electrons and watch
this i'm going all caps
only two
electrons can occupy an orbital
and orbital
that was paulie that's called the pauli
exclusion principle
okay so so now um
so we're gonna use all this information
to fill stuff up but i wanna
i don't wanna do that yet on wednesday
we're filling up the table and we're
making our first solid i figure
it's our three week anniversary i know
you've all been looking forward to it
i've been thinking about it a lot and i
think
that makes me want to throw t-shirts i
got to do this
[Applause]
all right all right i gotta go i i know
i i gotta go backwards here
[Applause]
okay okay hold on hold on oh
i got i'm missing there and there i know
i gotta work on my arm
yeah and there show you love over there
okay all right
i'll have more on wednesday and the
reason is
we're making our first solid i almost
wanted to leave it as a surprise but i
couldn't i couldn't help myself
it's extremely exciting this is after
all solid state chemistry
and wednesday we're making a solid
literally we are not only making
a bond but we're making a solid and
talking about solids so that's going to
be
very exciting and we're going to start
by filling
elements but before we do that i want to
explain
something very important which is
what's happening with energy right
we did just see something dramatic
as you go from bore to quantum something
very dramatic happens
with where right um
and and we know something else very
dramatic happens
which is right here you know that's bohr
over there
n equals one right there boar is one
two three right now it's like oh no wait
it's one and with one s
uh two and i can put two electrons in
there thanks to poly
i know i can put two because i'd have
all the quantum numbers in here the same
except spin which could be up or down
right
uh n equals one l equals zero m sub l
equals zero
spin is up or down two electrons but
look you see i'm now here at n equals
two
going from the bohr model to quantum
i've got this
and i've got three p orbitals
so now all of a sudden i've got eight
electrons that can go
into that quantum number that's very
different than bohr
right um and that's called degeneracy
because it's
you're taking something and you're
saying there are multiple variations
that have the same
n but there's something else that i want
to explain right now that is
that that can be understood very
physically and intuitively
and that is that you know the motivation
one of the big motivations of this
was that we needed more than one
electron right
our atoms are not all hydrogen and
ionized atoms
they are just neutral atoms going up
above hydrogen so what happens
when we go a multi-electron and there's
two effects that i want to explain
here's what happens to this picture
those are the one electron levels right
there's bora
over there this is what you really get
in terms of energy right this is energy
along the vertical axis and there's two
reasons
two very important reasons why these are
so different
one is called shielding and the other is
called orbital penetration and i want to
talk about both of them
in the last seven minutes of class
i'm going over here
all right so let's talk about let's do
shielding first
okay shielding
is something that you can kind of get a
very
good sense for it if you just look at
what's happening in these atoms
so in shielding
let's take an example i'm going to give
you a an atom with
15 protons and 15 electrons
what atom is it anybody know
phosphorus okay so i'm going to take an
example of the
phosphorus atom okay
and i've got 15
positive charges in the nucleus
15. right
now 15 protons now i've got
my levels and you know it gets very
difficult to draw
levels as probability distributions
so i'm going to draw them as rings even
though we know they're not right these
are my orbitals
but i've got like an electron here okay
an electron there
all right so i've got two electrons in
the n equals one
n equals one orbital so that's that's
the one s
orbital right there on the bottom okay
but if i go out
okay so i'm going to go out now
to n equals two well now i've got one
two three four
ah and oh boy
you know put one here five six
seven eight because here remember i've
got
l equals zero and l equals one and as we
just said
because m sub s can be up or down i've
got eight electrons here
right so i've got so here i've got n
equals one here i've got n equals two
that's eight electrons
and then out here oh now it gets really
interesting
because for n equals 3 how many
electrons do i have left
1 2 3 4 5.
and you can already see what's happening
so remember rutherford told us this
all this charge is in a tiny little
point here
you wouldn't even see it if we were
drawing this to scale
but what are these electrons seeing
what are the electrons seeing well you
know these inner two electrons are just
seeing this huge amount of charge
they are happy low energy
right the lower your energy the happier
you're in a lower energy ground state
remember
more lower energy more happiness
more bound right so
those electrons down there are enjoying
15 but these out here you see
these electrons let's say those
electrons in here
these shield the outer electrons
these shield outer electrons
by two electrons right
so because they're kind of in the way
it's like you got this negative charge
that's in between me and the positive
charge
right and and so so if i'm out here in n
equals 2 i don't see
i don't see right 15
positive charges there anymore i see 13.
ish that's shielding and if i'm right so
but now this one
this has you know the two the two s
and the two p electrons it's got eight
electrons there and those
are shielding another eight those are
shielding
another eight protons
so two two things outside of them right
you know that shielding doesn't work
going in
if i if i'm this electron
and i look out all i see are repulsive
i see repulsiveness in a good way i'm
sure they're friends
but they you know two negative charges
right so i'm only looking in looking in
shielded looking in shielded
right so these ones have sort of an
effective
z effective you know that could be
something like five this is this is not
the z of the atom but it's sort of like
those very outer electrons
don't see the whole proton cloud they
get shielded and that's a very important
part of what happens to orbitals when
you put a lot of electrons in them
and there's one more thing that happens
and it goes back to this plot
that i showed you before which is
that the orbitals themselves
are very different than just a
just like a straight line from bohr they
have these shapes to them
right so the second thing that happens
is that if i have that same
s you know this is s so this would now
be the 1s
and now i'm going to put remember that
2s looked like this
and it had the node there remember that
that was 2s right but now
we're going to put the 2p there this may
not be drawn to scale
okay here's the 2p
something very very interesting is
happening here and again it has to do
with what electrons are seeing
because the 2s electron has a
probability
remember this is the probability
normalized so we put an r squared there
right that that probability
all that means is if i integrate over
everything it's one it's got to be
somewhere
but look the 2s electron can be really
deep inside
the shells it can be in there
literally ins look it's even inside the
1s
so it gets some of that 15 proton action
right orbital penetration
leads to massive changes orbital
penetration is what this is called
and it allows some of the the
but the p doesn't have that it goes in a
little but the p doesn't have that peak
all the way in there where it can see
all that positive charge and that
is why these two things are different
you see because the 2s now can be closer
sometimes
to those 15 protons right and so it
lowers the energy making it happy
it finds a lower happy place okay so
we're going to use
this and next and on on wednesday
we're going to take these things and
we're going to fill them up and we're
going to make our first solid
have a very good rest of your day
you